es ist laut und eng im ankunftszentrum
in Waiblingen in Baden-Württemberg
hinter der Tür mit der Nummer 7 wohnt
diese Frau aus Donezk schon seit vier
Wochen ist sie hier jeden Tag sagt sie
denkt sie an ihre Heimatstadt die erst
kürzlich von Russland annektiert wurde
[Musik]
ich wünsche mir dass du jetzt wieder zur
Ukraine gehört und dieser Krieg endet
dass keine Menschen mehr kämpfen müssen
weder Militär noch Zivilisten und das in
der Ukraine wieder Frieden herrscht
danke schön
danke schön die Kabine teilt sie sich
mit ihrem Mann und einer anderen Familie
einer Mutter mit zwei Kindern dazu
kommen ihre Haustiere die Hunde und eine
Katze
wir gründen den Menschen die Tiere nicht
wegnehmen die standen weinend vor der
Tür beim Einzug aber das ist die einzige
Untergrund wo das überhaupt erlaubt ist
also sonst wäre das gar nicht möglich
der Lärm ist durchaus eine Belastung für
die anderen
mehr als 100 Menschen sind aktuell in
der Halle untergebracht mit Trennwänden
hat der Landkreis 24 Kabinen aufgebaut
Rückzugsräume zumindest ein bisschen
wenn zu viele Menschen zu eng wohnen
dann gibt es einfach Spannungen und
Schwierigkeiten und deshalb ist es
wichtig dass eine gewisse Privatsphäre
geschaffen wird auch dieses
ankunftszentrum war eigentlich immer
gedacht um die Menschen die erste
Registrierung die erste Versorgung mit
Kleidung Essen alles was man benötigt um
sie dann auf weitere Unterkünfte zu
verteilen das aber dauert weit länger
als geplant denn es kommen immer mehr
Menschen der Wohnraum in den Kommunen
reicht nicht seit Ende Februar wurden in
Deutschland mehr als eine Million
geflüchtete aus der Ukraine registriert
viele es tatsächlich sind unklar denn
Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer müssen in der
EU keinen Asylantrag stellen
Nikolai ist schon seit eineinhalb
Monaten hier mit 12 Verwandten floh er
aus ressen aktuell ist die Stadt von
Russland besetzt
ich habe kein Zuhause mehr an dass ich
zurückkehren könnte ich will nicht in
ein besetztes Gebiet zurückkehren wir
leben uns langsam ein aber wir hängen
völlig in der Luft wir haben überhaupt
noch keine Rechte können nichts machen
nur warten es gibt Menschen die sogar
zurückgehen weil sie es nicht aushalten
die Kabine war eigentlich für vier
Personen geplant jetzt sind sie zu
sechst
hier unten schläft er erklärt er
gegenüber sein Sohn oben sein
Schwiegersohn
allein im August musste der Landkreis
plötzlich mehr als 700 geflüchtete
unterbringen Zeit sich darauf
vorzubereiten hatten sie nicht für die
Haupt- und ehrenamtlichen Helfer der
Caritas eine Herausforderung Andrang bei
der Kleiderkammer und dem Sozialdienst
jetzt wirklich sehr viel schlechter geht
total viel los die Leute fragen die
wollen wissen wie geht es mit ihnen
weiter die wollen wissen wann ziehen sie
um wohin ziehen sie um weil sie
teilweise eben seit einem Monat oder
länger schon hier sind also das sind
wirklich dringende und dringende Fragen
von den Leuten was kommt als nächstes
auch für den Landrat die entscheidende
Frage jede Woche rechnet der Kreis mit
150 bis 209 geflüchteten dabei müssen
sie schon jetzt auf Notlösungen
zurückgreifen und auch die sind schon
gut belegt da war waren wir auch schon
im Geschäft es ist jetzt erheblich mehr
los muss man sagen die Strukturen haben
wir zwar damals alle sehr gut eingetütet
das funktioniert wunderbar aber es sind
doppelt so viele Menschen wie damals
wollen wir Zuweisungen bekommen wo wir
einfach nicht wissen wo wir Menschen
unterbringen dann gehen wir sozusagen in
die notnotunterkunft sie werden sehen da
ist sozusagen Bett an Bett gereiht
einfach die die Unterbringung wie Sie
vielleicht viele auch so ist aber was
wir sagen was eigentlich kein Standard
ist der gut funktioniert hier gibt es
dann überhaupt keine Privatsphäre mehr
glücklich ist damit niemand viele wollen
nicht gefilmt werden so eine Unterkunft
wollten wir immer vermeiden jetzt
mussten wir sie eröffnen weil einfach zu
viele Menschen kommen aber wie man sich
vorstellen kann hier länger als eine
Woche schlafen zu müssen leben zu müssen
ist eine unglaubliche Belastung alleine
wenn ich überlege nachts Kinder weinen
Männer schnarchen also die meisten sagen
sie kommen auch gar nicht zur Ruhe wir
können nicht mehr schlafen
in fast allen Bundesländern sind die
regulären Aufnahmekapazitäten
ausgeschöpft verstärkt werden hier wie
anderswo jetzt Sporthallen zur
Notunterkünften umfunktioniert
anders als 2015/16 wir haben zwei Jahre
Corona hinter uns wir müssen an den
Verein Sport denken wir müssen an den
Schulsport denken sonst bröckeln die
Akzeptanz und deshalb bauen wir
inzwischen auch Zelte auf so schnell wie
möglich viele Schlafplätze schaffen ein
paar Orte weiter in Backnang hat der
Kreis dafür jetzt innerhalb weniger
Wochen eine kleine Zeltstadt aus dem
Boden gestampft Platz für mehr als 400
Menschen drei Wohnzelte je zwei zum
kochen waschen und gemeinsam essen reden
und spielen dazu 20 Sanitärcontainer
alles neu und trotzdem ist die Zeltstadt
nicht mehr als ein Backup die letzte
Option wenn alle anderen Unterkünfte
voll sind
gesetzt 2015/16 aber gesagt haben die
Zelte sind eigentlich schlechteste
Alternative aber die Situation ist so
unplanbar dass man einfach sagen wir
bereiten uns vor wir schaffen
Kapazitäten dass wir einfach in der Lage
sind auch zu reagieren nicht planen zu
können eine der größten
Herausforderungen für die Landkreise und
Kommunen das ist die dramatischen Bilder
von 2015 aktuell noch nicht gibt hat vor
allem einen Grund es gibt enorme
Hilfsbereitschaft ist immer super
dankbar aus der Mitte der Bevölkerung
die mehrere hundert Personen in privatem
Wohnraum untergebracht haben aber
trotzdem die absolute Zahlen haben jetzt
mittlerweile Dimension erreicht solche
Notlösungen erforderlich machen dringend
brauche es mehr Verlässlichkeit und
Unterstützung aus Stuttgart und Berlin
fordert der Landrat genau wie die
Oberbürgermeister der Großen Kreisstädte
im Rems-Murr-Kreis in einem gemeinsamen
Brief schreiben Sie wir stehen hier
buchstäblich mit dem Rücken zur Wand
dies gelte für Wohnraum Sozialbetreuung
ausländerrechtliche Behandlung und die
finanzielle Lage der Städte
Maximilian Friedrich ist einer der
Unterzeichner es sei selbstverständlich
und wichtig zu helfen aber
gleichzeitig wollen wir doch auch darauf
hinweisen dass das eine enorme Belastung
insgesamt darstellt für die Städte und
Gemeinden dass uns gewisser Hinsicht
eine gesellschaftliche Zerreißprobe
droht und dass wir an vielen Stellen
Unterstützung brauchen sowohl in
finanzieller Hinsicht aber auch in der
Hinsicht das ist zwingend eine
europäische Verteilungsgerechtigkeit
Bedarf zurück in Waiblingen im
ankunftszentrum ist gerade eine Liste
vom Landratsamt gekommen für die
Menschen hier die entscheidende Liste
die über ihr weiteres Leben in
Deutschland bestimmt Umzüge stehen an
erstmal ins Ungewisse ich habe jetzt
eine Liste bekommen von Leuten die jetzt
am Dienstag ausziehen es sind ziemlich
viele so um die 30 würde ich sagen und
ich habe gerade festgestellt dass das
die Leute sind die eigentlich erst am
Mittwoch angekommen sind andere warten
seit eineinhalb Monaten dass es endlich
voran geht Frust bei denen die da
bleiben müssen
mich muss sie irgendwie beruhigen und
runterbringen und so weiter und aber
vielleicht ich glaube man muss ja dem
Landratsamt auch sagen die schauen
natürlich auch wer passt in welche
Unterkunft ist es eine Unterkunft mit
vielen Kindern dann kommt da Familie mit
Kindern hin hat Schorndorf gerade Platz
Oleander markenko überbringt die guten
Nachrichten diese Frau aus Odessa ist
froh dass es jetzt weitergeht
hoffentlich künftig ein gemütlicherer
Platz trotzdem auch hier gehe es ihr gut
sagt sie
wir wurden hier sehr gut aufgenommen den
Erwachsenen geht es mal so mal so aber
die Kinder fühlen sich wohl das ist das
Wichtigste
auch Alexey hat heute Glück er floh mit
Frau und Sohn aus
donezküche ich möchte mich möglichst
schnell in der Gesellschaft integrieren
nicht von Sozialleistung Leben ich
möchte auch einen Arbeitsplatz finden
er ist glücklich dass er umziehen darf
obwohl er nicht weiß was ihn und seine
Familie in Schorndorf erwartet
wir wissen halt nicht warum es geht ob
es eine Wohnung ist ob es jetzt ein
Container ist ob es jetzt eine andere
Sammelunterkunft ist also niemand weiß
das also sie werden das vor Ort ja
erfahren dann geht Oleander weiter sucht
die nächsten die vom Landkreis in die
Obhut der Kommune wechseln ihre Plätze
hier werden schon bald von den nächsten
Flüchtenden gebraucht